hey guys how's it go here's the speed
and today you my kitchen is John what's
up this is so exciting because he
actually knows how to cook like real
food hey you know you know what you're
doing too we just made a video for my
channel and you cooked your pants off I
was quite surprised it actually turned
out really well I'll put a link in the
description where you guys can check
that out but today we're celebrating
something super exciting oh yes we are
on chopped can you chop the show on Food
Network yes where we compete against
each other this will be out on Tuesday
March 28th so I hope you guys will check
it out some of you already have figured
it out because you guys spotted me in
the promo and you're like what just seen
cooking yeah
as you guys know I have been beyond
obsessed and smell the breath of the
wild and my Nintendo switch a hundred
hours yeah more than kind of crazy in
the game wink actually does some cooking
and I thought this would be a great
video that we can do we can cook some
things that wing cooks in the game I'm
gonna be making a meat fewer okay pretty
simple yeah and a spicy steamed to me
pretty simple
glazed meat spicy sauteed peppers sounds
good I'm tweaking me and mushroom skewer
don't really know what that is but I'm
excited to find out one game when you
make it you mix it with different
various ingredients and then it gives
you special powers like there's a good
sneaky power yeah it makes you receive
me this is me speaking my mind Susie she
is so awesome
she got me bit if you link me out of
balloon that is one of the most
impressive things I've ever seen
secret balloon art it's crazy who would
have focus but all the fun in Messier
maybe how to play the game I'm going to
show you a quick clip here this is how
you cook and I'm going to show you too
since you have a plated either we're
gone it's pretty easy you basically
select these items if you want as you
want to deal with the recipe for join 1
par spicy sauteed peppers and it's
basically just 5 peppers 5 spicy peppers
spicy peppers that makes you able to
withstand cold climates oh it makes
sense so you need to sauteed spicy
peppers menu kid walks through liquor so
yeah you're good but not the same world
but yes a growing same different order
it's ok whales order everything pretty
much from Amazon
and I didn't really know what to get any
of us let me just let me get my
ingredients
okay okay this is it looks like a spicy
pepper when a picture they are red these
are not by food
oh yeah they're sweet sweet mini peppers
hmm but for the sake of this cooking
demonstration I think we should yeah
yeah look so here's the mushroom here's
the mushroom a regular white bread
mushrooms white bread yeah I mean like
white like they're just like regular
white mushrooms yeah they look like the
picture button mushrooms oh cool oh I
hate mushroom so much these are the same
as these but pre-sliced huh
yeah you learn something new every day
in the kitchen I didn't read the
description on Amazon so also if you
guys aren't from this sort of like a
bigger city you can get things on Amazon
like food I ordered all of this stuff
even the burn I don't know what I got I
just ordered a bunch of me okay well you
definitely have a lot of steak going on
here
yes this doesn't look like we're going
to need it today
listen ro for that dinner party that you
want to invite me over to will cook this
roast beef okay what if this is a full
row okay like this is this is a big hunk
of meat over here yeah do you even do
with that like the raw prime meat in the
game yeah that's that's probably
something around me it's vodka yeah so
we should probably freeze that
definitely freezes what should one of
these usually I'm all y'all you saw the
picture yeah basically we just got to
make this I mean I actually don't know
how to cook a steak at all well I think
part of the fun of what we're about to
do is we're about to teach you and
consequently everyone at home how to
properly cook a steak and also make
itself a theme let's get prepping I
don't know what to do grab some olive
oil and some steak seasoning now if you
don't have steak seasoning salt and
pepper will be it okay cool
a bead of rock salt in the game Oh
perfect
Oh what's this this is uh it's up to you
I mean this is a Stacy some sort of
steak seasoning there as you could see
Justine she cooks a lot but she mainly
bakes as evidence that you've never
opened neither this nor this all right
let's get there's a plastic cutting
board I saw and the reason we're using
plastic is because it's me and when you
put meat on wood it contaminates the
wood thanks it
yeah Rose you know your ID you know that
that's one thing I learned from my mom
so what's the first one that you want to
make oh boy let's get in Booker or
meteor first okay if you were to get
also do the meteor in the mushroom
spirit same time okay okay let me go get
my face okay I got some skewers good and
he's a good choice that's a great choice
okay doing skewers is one of the most
versatile tools and you can have in the
kitchen in so even though you probably
will only be using them for this recipe
guarantee you liam again for something
else
you know what i actually use these
forward with a testing cake to see if
they're done there you go so we're going
to cut a little medina because that's
what the picture looks like yes right so
I don't know we're going to make was it
four of them I'm cutting what I think is
those neat medallions look how beautiful
that looks the game they really only
have like rock salt a seasoning okay
okay look be true to the game and yeah
let's do it
I know it's on the game but we don't
want to stick the pen so we're gonna a
small well do I put it on the pan don't
fit on the state really yeah yep there
you go perfect brick would solve a how
do you never seen it I don't know
exactly if you guys have been doing a
design I just seen doesn't know the
solve a knob a walls big pain light like
behave like before anything else yeah
yeah oh really
please good like like you're basically
salt
this is incredible
whoa the fizzle is real
now we wait go away I don't want to get
into crow that old boy welcome to this
don't you
well the look is little nose is moving
so fast
[Music]
we can eat and look and feel yeah okay
so my car it goes sideways don't stab
yourself I'm Charlie I don't burn myself
yeah true oh that's not me and then
finally again yeah I don't resolve it
look good okay
so hungy Rena even after hearing all the
meals we already made I know wow there
is a lot of stuff going on that is
beautiful next fewer we've got our
you're done he was a gun now on to the
next one
what do you think we should make max
let's make the flavor glaze one okay
please which troubled
now that's developing me is the people
would ever actually make I mean I don't
I never thought of that before I don't
know yes I know truffles and sake of a
thing honey
I don't know wow that is pretty huge
piece of me I really excited
should I put a fan on you want you maybe
oh thank you first kids always use
sounds cuz it's a car so we we got our
meat it's done and now we've got our
little teeny tiny pot yeah
with this kind of sort of Zelda inspired
I really thought it was gonna be a
little bit bigger I think he did a
pretty good job it looks like the ones
who does it it should be are the biggest
economy it's alright it's fine so right
now we're gonna be making our mushroom
and honey glaze yeah it's more than the
truffle one now what do you think about
this what is this that I bought is this
is ground-up truffle this is something
that you would be able to put on a steak
or some sort of to look like maybe a
sandwich I don't want this put it in
there right yeah amen
- honey wait yeah Wow he's eyeballing
this there's no measuring either yeah
and that I just heated up so I don't
connect to this although it's very hot
for anything very strong right yeah it's
definitely something with resistance
right and now we can look a week late
yeah I'm just I'm taking your lead
because I have a played this game before
so put in the game you don't do it and
you take a bunch of food and throw it in
the pot and it's just made cool so let's
if that's the case and that's what we
did
- glazing it itself really interesting
we need to take a taste of it before on
before under we now lost the one okay I
got you good much right ready Oh Cheers
[Music]
oh absolutely really light is really
good in truffle and honey steak sauce
holy moly we just invent something whoa
I'm game linkage
[Music]
yeah our last one is might be seen D
spicy seems me what does he do you just
teach it throws it in your eyes that
baby well looks good
funny plan intended by metric here warm
subpoena and raw meat
alright quite sure what subpoena is uh
you know it's we're going to just find
out Hyrule Castle you know yours nearer
mm okay we're gonna season it with some
olive oil have a plan well I've got some
basil here that's a plan you don't need
any time haha I like that time pass the
word of my Apple watch goes you know
what do I get off I think maybe we do
it's right there next to a thing Oh what
do you got what do you got I've got
ground time perfect
I'm leaving the one for some serious
Sofia good time
program Chiluba google are huge to me
look at it
like a goal now solvers all right are
you that was incredible or even just
flip it this way i have it yeah a little
it looks so perfect I can't believe it
that is a Zelda voice and it looks
incredible
this is contained me to father can't
believe are you ready I can't believe it
either this is magical other spices
I think the baggie said that they were
sweet we try them sweet I really do
definitely sweet well that's definitely
sweet yeah this is not this is not slave
you know it's not even sauteed know what
oh well cheating not only made all over
items what showcase our delicious case
that we just made we should do that
spicy steamed meat looks pretty good I
mean it looks pretty much identical and
we got our meat skewer needs here also
look identical pretty good
meaty meat a mushroom skewer spot-on
yeah all right now looks really good and
then we've got our glazed meat which I
am the bun will really surprised at how
good that actually make worship if you
guys want to try a new treat is a new
glaze on e and truffle and then last but
not least we've got our spicy sauteed
peppers and that's why we're sorry
they're sweet peppers peppers a funny
not for pain but you get the idea
well thank you again for helping me and
make sure you guys do check out the
video that we did on josh's channel also
link description annotations wherever
those happen to be and most importantly
will be unchopped
on tuesday
got so excited I can't wait my suspicion
is killing women to be so incredible and
I'm so excited it was so much fun
no lying no spoilers I'm just excited
and honored to have it on the show so it
was so much fun Pekka thanks for having
me on your show yeah come on cook any
time we eat oh yes you can
yeah and also I want you to teach me how
to play Zelda do you have 120 some hours
to dedicate to like not doing anything
but playing a game I mean it's a team
making videos and playing them down yeah
perfect done okay guys bye I always say
I'm not going to do it this time I'm not
I don't need it we're not we're not
going to do it well then here we are at
it again does not approve I'm just gonna
close my eyes and I'm not here all these
empty faces back of the problems I don't
care
[Music]